Hello and welcome to another episode of
What's Up Prof.
Good day Walter.
Hi Martin.
We're continuing where we left off the
last previous episode.
Yes.
We're going to talk about the truth will
set you free part two.
And like we stated in the previous
episodes,
truth is everything and we have to know
what is truth. I read last night in
selected messages,
without truth, sanctification is
impossible.
See, that's that's just to show how
important it is. So, let's pray and
let's
start the discussion.
Our heavenly Father,
thank you once again for the privilege
of having these discussions.
We ask that you bless them, enlighten
our minds with the Holy Spirit in Jesus'
name. Amen.
Martin, some people will think that we
are just trying to be contrary.
And this issue of Bible translations is
one that
becomes very emotional.
But, you know, it is a subject
that is of such utmost importance.
Because
when you think about the fact that God
says man shall not live by bread alone,
but by every word that proceeds out of
the mouth of the Lord,
isn't it of paramount importance that
you really have the words of the Lord?
And as we saw in the last episode,
that hundreds of words
and whole portions are just missing
and they they blame it on conflation.
But, this is the scripture that was used
in the first centuries.
And it was used all the way
up to 1844.
And if you think about the early
Protestant movement from the time that
Martin Luther and Tyndale translated the
scriptures into German and into English
and thereafter into all the other
languages that the scriptures are
available in.
Those hundreds of years, do we really
want to believe that they had the wrong
scriptures and the Roman Catholic Church
by its wisdom gave us the real things
after discovering during the Reformation
this manuscript with half the portions
missing
and thousands of corrections in it in
the Vatican library and in 1844 the
Sinaiticus found in a waste paper basket
with so many scratches and cutouts and
corrections in it that those are the
be-alls and end-alls
and everybody else was wrong in between?
So, this is absolutely to me a
nonsensical
way of thinking. I agree with you. The
Bible and the Spirit of Prophecy makes
it clear that God will protect and
secure his word.
Yes. So, now you get people like you
say, "Oh, no, but for the
that period, sorry, it was the wrong
word." Yes, then you had the the
scriptures that were in Latin from the
Roman Catholic Church,
Jerome's Vulgate,
which was based on Eusebius' manuscripts
and not anything else. He was a big fan
of Eusebius.
And the Spirit of Prophecy that tells us
clearly that the situation was
different, that the Waldenses had the
true scriptures. Now, if you go back in
history, Martin,
and you go to the Byzantine Church,
Antioch,
that is where early Christians were
called Christians for the first time.
This is where Paul operated. This is
where the manuscripts were. Why would
you
ignore the Antioch scriptures and
go for the Alexandrian ones? Where
Gnosticism was the name of the game.
Yes, it it doesn't make any sense.
But, it seems as if the scholarly world
has swallowed this this line of thinking
hook, line, and sinker. Another point,
of course, is
the original scriptures were written in
Greek. The New Testament, I'm talking
about, not the Old Testament, was
written in Greek.
And it was written in Koine Greek.
And
the the scholars
of the Alexandrian school, they had
classical Greek,
which was of such a higher status. The
other one was, you know, like Every man
can like kitchen Afrikaans.
Every person could understand what it
was all about and you know, it's it's
just like God to want to reach everybody
and not just a certain elite group.
And the first translations that we find
are actually
Armenian.
And they're based on the received text.
And the entire Byzantine Church,
the Greek Orthodox Church, until very
recently used only received text
translations. It's only in the last
decades
that there this change has come about.
So, all of this history, God made a
terrible mistake.
He must have given, you know, the wrong
manuscripts to the greatest portion of
history
and fortunately we have the Roman
Catholic manuscripts to set us straight.
That makes no sense whatsoever.
But, today we want to talk about how it
affects doctrine.
And this is not an attack. This is just
a plain statement of the status quo.
Yes. People must decide. Decide and use
some logic with it. Yes.
So,
again we start off with John 8:32 and
you shall know the truth and the truth
shall make you free.
This word truth is of such utmost
important.
And the last one we spoke about Jesus
being the truth and we discussed some of
those issues. The word is truth and the
final one is the law, the commandments
are truth. So, let's look at some of
these issues.
So, what we want to talk about is
Adventist doctrine and the new
translations.
So, let's make a few comparisons. Daniel
chapter 9:25-26.
This is the King James version. Know
therefore and understand that from the
going forth of the commandment to
restore and to build Jerusalem
unto the Messiah the prince
shall be seven weeks and three score and
two weeks. The street shall be built
again and the wall, even in troublous
times. And after three score and two
weeks shall Messiah be cut off, but not
for himself.
And the people of the prince that shall
come shall destroy the city and the
sanctuary
and the end thereof shall be with a
flood and unto the end of the war
desolations are determined.
Now, this prophecy is an extremely
important prophecy. Right.
It is the prophecy of prophecies.
It tells us the exact time when the
Messiah the prince would come.
And it tells us what will happen to him.
And it gives us a deadline, the 70 week
prophecy. Isn't it beautiful?
It's amazing because like we've
mentioned in the previous episode, the
Jews weren't studying
present truth. No.
That's why they missed this prophecy.
Yes.
They missed this prophecy and uh
to this day they miss this prophecy and
they
pervert it.
But, this statement that the Messiah
will be cut off, but not for himself, is
such a profound prophetic statement.
And
they contrast the two princes. The one
is the prince of Rome
that'll come and destroy the city, the
literal prince, and that one has an
antitype, which is the Antichrist, who
is also of Roman origin.
And you have this play between the two
princes.
The prince of the covenant and this
other prince.
Now, if you read this prophecy in the
NIV, for example, it says, "Know and
understand this from the issuing of the
decree
to restore and rebuild Jerusalem until
the anointed one,
the ruler comes. There will be 7 sevens
and 62 sevens.
It will be rebuilt with streets and a
trench, but in times of trouble. After
the 62 sevens, the anointed one will be
cut off and will have nothing.
The people of the ruler who will come
will destroy the city and the sanctuary.
The end will come like a flood. War will
continue until the end and desolation
has been decreed."
Now, if you take the Jesuitical view of
the Antichrist and how they deal with
the Antichrist in prophecy,
they, of course, introduce either
preterism or futurism.
And if you take this prophecy, they can
use this to introduce their
dispensationalist ideas.
And this anointed one, yes, the Messiah
is the anointed one.
That is correct, but the anointed one
was also applied to any other ruler.
Yeah, king. And and to a priest that was
anointed. Yeah. So,
it is very non-specific, whereas the
King James puts it in a very specific
context.
Let's just unpack that little bit.
When Jesus said, "The time is fulfilled"
in Mark 1:15,
it was a reference to this prophecy.
Because that happened in 27 AD. That's
why this such an important prophecy.
Yes.
Uh in the fullness of time, God sent
forth his son. Mhm. Right?
Now, the fullness of time, what time?
And then Jesus comes up out of the water
and he says, "The time is fulfilled."
What time is fulfilled?
The prophetic time of Daniel.
Exactly.
So, when did God send forth his son?
Well, you could reason from the birth,
but when did his ministry start? At the
baptism.
It started at the baptism, and that's
where Jesus said, "The time is
fulfilled." And the prophecy of Daniel
ends in 27 AD, which happens to be the
baptism.
And that's when he said, "It's
finished." Yes. And that is when the war
between Christ and Satan reached a
climax
in the wilderness.
And where Adam failed, the first Adam,
the second Adam redeemed the failure.
Yeah. So, he vanquished Satan in the
wilderness.
At the cross, he paid the price for sin.
The wages of sin is death.
That's it. And as the representative of
the human race,
he took the the penalty upon himself.
And he already had the victory in the
wilderness. Correct.
Now,
the anointed one could be any priest or
king, but the Messiah who was cut off,
but not for himself,
puts this issue beyond doubt. Yeah.
So, what does it mean that the anointed
one will have nothing?
That's what the new translation says.
Well, it means exactly that, nothing.
But Jesus gained everything and not
nothing.
And when he was cut off for our
transgressions, that was the great
victory cry.
He regained what had been forfeited to
Satan and will rule as King of kings for
all eternity. The foe was vanquished and
the eternal victory was achieved. So,
does it matter, Martin, whether the
Messiah gained everything or nothing?
Of course, it matters. Our salvation
depends on it. Yes.
So, in my opinion,
the translation
is an affront,
the new translations, to to God. Yeah.
What about the ministry of Jesus in the
sanctuary?
Hebrews 9:12, "Neither by the blood of
goats and calves, but by his own blood
he entered in once into the holy place,
having obtained eternal redemption for
us." King James version.
If you take the New King James version,
which, by the way,
differs from the received text in 1,200
places, at least.
Yeah.
"Not with the blood of goats and calves,
but with his own blood he entered the
most holy place once for all, having
obtained eternal redemption."
The NIV says exactly the same thing. "It
did not enter by means of the blood of
goats and calves, but he entered the
most holy place once for all by his own
blood,
thus obtaining eternal redemption." Now,
Martin, is the the word of God a small
God's board where you pick and choose
what you want? No, especially if you got
this important doctrine.
This is one of the foundational
doctrines that sets the Seventh-day
Adventists separate from the rest.
Right. So, here the King James
translates it as holy place.
The New King James translates it as most
holy place, and the NIV does the same.
So, there is a choice now. Did he go
into the holy place? Did he go into the
most holy place? Well, it's very clear
that he didn't enter in with the blood
of goats and calves, but with his own
blood.
When was that blood available, Martin?
After he lived his life on Earth. So,
after the cross, right?
So, if the earthly sanctuary was a type
of the heavenly sanctuary,
and no ministry could take place in the
sanctuary, either in the holy place or
in the most holy place, without blood,
and if Jesus didn't enter in with the
blood of goats and calves, but with his
own blood, then where should his
ministry begin? In the holy place or in
the most holy place?
holy place. It's it's logical.
Otherwise, the entire Old Testament
typology is null and void.
That's it. And you destroy the time
prophecy again
of the two um 2,300
evenings and mornings.
Yes. Because then it can't then he
what he did
of by going into the most holy in 1844
is then negated. Then you don't have a
culmination of the 2,300-day prophecy of
Daniel, either.
And the other interesting thing is, even
if you take the Hebrew itself,
there's a difference between hagion and
hagia hagion.
And uh hagia hagion is used for the most
holy place, but this only says hagion,
so why translate it most holy place?
Now,
hagion just means sanctuary.
But this uh
the various portions were all part of
the sanctuary. So, the translation in
the King James version is the only one
that makes theological
typological
sense.
And it's very, very important. Because
by changing this one aspect, you get rid
of 1844,
you get rid of the investigative
judgment,
and therefore, you can also play around
with the other prophecies in the book of
Daniel as to the fact whether judgment
was given in favor of the saints or
whether judgment was handed over to the
saints. There's a big difference. A big
time gap between those two events.
So, everything becomes confused by this
simple change.
This change gets rid of Adventism.
That's it. Because it makes 1844
obsolete. Mhm.
Now, people will want to say, "But 1844,
where do you get it from?"
Well, it comes from Daniel's prophecy of
the 70 weeks, of which we just read the
introduction, the Messianic portion.
Yes, inside of the 2,300. Yes. Yes. But
the cleansing of the sanctuary, the
antitypical day of atonement, is also
within that prophecy, because the
Messiah's work was not completed at the
cross. The victory was won because there
were generations that were still to come
that needed an advocate, that needed a
mediator.
And that mediation took place in the
holy and then finally transferred to the
most holy at the end of the 2,300-day
prophecy.
By changing this, you're throwing that
out of the water, and every evangelical
doctrine manipulated by Jesuitical
thinking can now apply. You have a small
God's board available. Here, you don't.
Yes, on the King James version, it is
set. You cannot play around with it.
So, let's just make this quite clear.
The received text,
Once you start using that
and any translation that is based on
that will largely follow the same
example as the King James used here. If
you go to the early versions of the
translations on the received text. So,
this is a very important subject and the
new translations totally destroy the
doctrine.
What about the Sabbath and the law of
God? This is a very important issue,
don't you think so, Martin?
It's a salvation issue.
Now, this question of the law
has the law been abrogated?
No, because
Jesus said, "Not one tittle of the law
will be
put away before the end comes." All
right.
So, the law stands.
Does Jesus say, "If you love me, keep my
commandments?"
Does John say, "He who says he loves
loves him and does not keep his
commandments is a liar and the truth is
not in him." Yes.
Okay, so these are very important
things.
So, the law
is immutable.
Does that mean that the penalty of the
law
or the penalty of the transgression of
the law, is that also immutable?
Definitely. All right. So, the justice
of God demands
exactly that justice.
And justice for transgression of the law
is the death penalty.
But, the law is immutable. Not one jot
or one tittle will by any means
disappear from the law.
Mhm?
So, the law stands. Yep.
That means justice must be done.
It's a dilemma.
Because if God wants to forgive
that means there's no justice.
The two are mutually exclusive. If you
forgive the transgressor and let him go,
then there's no justice.
It's a very simple situation.
Let's say somebody murders your beloved
child or daughter and does even worse
things.
Comes before the courts.
The penalty
in the old days was death for that kind
of crime.
The man says, "I'm sorry for what I
did." The judge says, "I accept your
apology. You may go free." How will the
parents of the murdered child feel?
Unjustified. No justice.
Justice demands the death penalty. God
didn't deal with it lightly. He took it
upon himself and he bore the penalty in
his flesh.
And in order to do that, he had to
condescend
to become a human being
to identify with us. That's amazing.
and this is actually it's actually a
slap in God's face if you say the law is
not applicable anymore. Well Because he
had to die to show that it is.
So, the death of Jesus on the cross
is the greatest guarantee that the law
stands.
Exactly.
Whereas the evangelical world says the
death on the cross is the the proof that
the law has been abrogated, has been
done away with. You see, they they
confuse the two. They say God has so
much love that he forgives you.
But, he has so much love that he died
for you and that is to show that the law
is
he stands for it. He took he shows you,
"Look, my love for you is so great that
I'll take the penalty of this law that
still stands." So, in other words
justice
and mercy
kissed each other
at the cross.
So, when we read in Exodus 20:8-12,
the law regarding the Sabbath and we
read it in the King James, it says,
"Remember the Sabbath day to keep it
holy.
Six days shalt thou labor and do all thy
work, but the seventh day is the Sabbath
of the Lord thy God.
In it thou shalt not do any work, thou,
nor thy son, nor thy daughter, thy man
servant, nor thy maid servant, nor thy
cattle, nor thy stranger that is within
thy gates. For
in six days the Lord made heaven and
earth, the sea, and all that in them is
and rested the seventh day.
Therefore, the Lord blessed the Sabbath
day and hallowed it."
Let's jump to the NIV.
"Remember the Sabbath day by keeping it
holy.
Six days you shall labor and do all your
work.
But, the seventh day is a
sabbath."
That's a big problem, Martin. Yep.
Is it the Sabbath or is it a sabbath? If
it's a sabbath, could be anything,
right?
To the Lord your God, on it you shall
not do any work, neither you, nor your
son or daughter, nor your man servant,
nor your maid servant, nor your animals,
nor the alien within your gates. For in
six days the Lord made the heavens, the
earth, the sea, and all that in them is,
but he rested on the seventh day.
Therefore, the Lord blessed the Sabbath
day and made it holy."
Just changing
this one little tiny
definite article
and you have a major
theological issue on your hands.
Is it a sabbath or is it the sabbath?
This whole
section
goes about
the Sabbath of the Lord.
So, if you make it a sabbath
whose is it then? All right. Now,
another question.
If it is a definitive
law of God
then only the King James version is
valid because this one is an indefinite
command.
Well, it can be every any day. Yes. All
right. So, your your loved one tells
you, "I'm arriving at 10:00 on
Wednesday."
And you say, "All right, she's arriving
on a on on a day this week sometime.
I'll go and pick her up on a Thursday."
That'll work very well, right?
You'll be in trouble.
Okay. So, there are definite differences
here and the difference is small.
But, it is a major.
The seventh day is the Sabbath of the
Lord thy God and not a sabbath. Never in
scripture is the seventh day Sabbath
referred to as a sabbath.
So, the absence of a definite article in
the Hebrew does not give one the right
to substitute a for the.
The NIV repeats this travesty of justice
in Deuteronomy 5:14.
In Genesis 2:1-3, God emphasizes that it
is the Sabbath three times and there's
no record of him having rested on any
other day.
So, it's just not biblical. So, which
one's right?
Definitely the King James version. And
the other one must be wrong. Yep.
And if a theologian tells you that
you're not a biblical critical scholar,
therefore you have no right to to talk
about these things
well, then
nobody has any right to use any language
to talk.
Because obviously only they are then
able to define which wording is
acceptable and even if it says the
opposite, why it is still acceptable.
That makes no sense whatsoever.
How do you make sense of this that you
have to be a biblical scholar or a
theologian to understand this, but Jesus
gave the Bible to everybody and he said
that you must believe like a child.
Yes, and he sent fishermen into the
world to go and preach the gospel.
So, actually that is academic arrogance
of the highest order.
So, in Acts 13:42, you have the
interesting story where Paul was
preaching to the Jews
and then the Gentiles requested that
they also hear these messages
and they would come the next Sabbath to
listen to this issue.
And when the Jews were gone out of the
synagogue, the Gentiles besought that
these words might be preached to them
the next Sabbath. That's the King James
version.
As Paul and Barnabas, this is the NIV
were leaving the synagogue
the people invited them to speak further
about these things on the next Sabbath.
There's a fundamental difference here.
Firstly, the Jews are gone.
It's now Paul and Barnabas were leaving
the synagogue
and the people. Yeah.
So, that can include the Jews again. It
could be anyone, right?
So, the scriptures are clear here that
the King in the King James that Sabbath
is the day on which the Jews worshipped
and where he was preaching on the
Sabbath day in the synagogue.
Why do the new versions leave this
reference to the Jews out and hide this
simple statement of fact?
Is it because it reflects poorly on
Sunday keeping?
The King James makes it clear that both
Jews and Gentiles received this message
on the seventh day Sabbath.
Now, Martin
the reformers
that translated the Bible into the King
James version here
they were very very meticulous.
They had a committee.
And even people outside of the committee
that received the original text as it
stands in the received text and they had
to translate it and once they had
consensus on the translation, it was
included.
Now, there are so many people that say
now, you know
King James, he wasn't the greatest king
of all and some say he was a Mason and
some say this and that about him.
Does it matter? He wasn't the translator
of the of the Bible. He didn't translate
it. He's the com- the committee.
And was there a war against that
translation committee? Didn't Guy
Fawkes, Jesuit and his Jesuit crew
want to blow up the parliament, king and
translators, and the entire parliament
that was for the Protestant cause?
Didn't they want to blow them up? Yes.
Is that war forgotten? No.
No, it's celebrated every year. Yes, but
for the wrong reasons, right? You just
blow up crackers, but you don't know
what happened in history and nobody has
a clue.
Now, Martin, it's interesting.
There's a possibility. Now, I'm I'm
conjecturing.
But the favorite Bible
the very favorite Bible of the
Protestant world was the Geneva Bible.
But the Geneva Bible had very elaborate
footnotes.
And they were very direct. They called a
spade a spade.
They were like
some of our study Bibles.
A few of our study Bibles that will
still say it as it is. So, when you read
in Daniel, for example, and you read
about the little horn
some of our study Bibles will say
directly who the little horn is. It is
the Antichrist, the papal system.
That's what some will say.
Some of our study Bibles
have become very reticent to say that
and remove that portion.
Now, this is very interesting. So, the
Geneva Bible had very elaborate
footnotes.
And when it comes to Thessalonians and
the man of sin and all of these things
they were very specific. Now, do you
think this is a Rome?
Definitely.
Okay.
So, let's take a hypothetical scenario.
Let's make a worst-case scenario and say
that King James
was in the bag as far as Rome was
concerned.
I'm not saying it is so. I'm just saying
even worst-case scenario, even if he was
a Roman agent himself.
And he gave permission to the
Protestants who had control over the
parliament.
Cuz this was a very interesting way in
which it worked. It took away the power
of the one and gave it to
the whole group, right, in parliament.
If he gave permission
some are saying that
the permission was granted on condition
that there be no footnotes.
That would have been an interesting
first step to get rid of the
incriminating
footnotes that were in the Geneva Bible.
It's a possibility.
Uh some will shout conspiracy theory,
but that's fine.
So
even if King James
was as we say
an agent of Rome
it still doesn't change the fact that
the translators translated the received
text and wrote down what God said.
Correct.
At a later stage, when the footnotes are
then gone, maybe then they can start
introducing changes to the text so that
they can get their new theology
accepted by the world. And they used
agents like Westcott and Hort who in my
opinion and in the opinion of many many
writers were nothing other than closet
Jesuits.
Just like Newman and the Oxford Movement
was probably also one of them.
So, having said that
let's continue with what the NIV did
over here.
So, they changed it to Paul and Barnabas
and they changed the Gentiles into
people.
Let's take another doctrine.
The state of the dead. So, we've seen
that the Sabbath
is definitely
watered down
and
made so wishy-washy that you can put
anything into into it other than the
seventh day, right?
Let's look at the state of the dead.
There are many verses which we could
quote here, but let's just for the sake
of brevity
talk about only a few. Although many
verses could be quoted here, we will
quote only two which are painfully
contrary to the sound doctrine in modern
versions.
Second Peter 2:9, The Lord knoweth how
to deliver the godly out of temptations
and to reserve the unjust unto the day
of judgment to be punished. King James.
Plain, simple, easy to understand.
NIV, If this is so, then the Lord knows
how to rescue godly men from trials and
to hold the unrighteous for the day of
judgment while continuing their
punishment.
Where does this nonsense come from?
Rome. Let's call it nonsense.
So, to say that this is equally inspired
as the as the translation in the King
James
is absolutely nonsense.
So, firstly, the NIV questions the
previous statement by commencing the
sentence with if this is so.
So,
who else said
if this is so? Satan did in the
beginning with Eve.
Okay. Did God really say?
This sounds very ominous to me.
And then they confuse temptations with
trials.
Because let's read it again over here in
the King James. The Lord knows how to
deliver the godly out of temptation
and to reserve the unjust unto the day
of judgment to be punished. So, they
translate temptations as trials.
This is nonsense because God promises to
keep us from temptation in the Lord's
Prayer but assures us that that we will
have trials.
Now, the NIV says God will keep us from
trials, which is not even true. It's not
even biblical.
Which proves that the NIV rendition must
be erroneous and not even biblical.
Moreover, the verse opens the way for
erroneous readings of scripture
including the false doctrine of
purgatory and everlasting hell because
it says it continues their punishment
after the day of judgment.
So, Martin, is this Roman Catholic or is
this Protestant? Definitely a Roman
Catholic.
Okay. Now, Martin Luther which text did
he translate?
The received text. Okay. Did Martin
Luther, on the strength of that study
believe
that the dead know nothing and that they
sleep until the day of judgment?
Yes. And he had to change his mind
because that wasn't what he believed
before. No, he was a Roman Catholic
priest before that.
So, in other words, is it important
whether you translate it like this or
like this?
Let's ask another question. Is it two
different doctrines?
Yes. Hm? Yeah, completely. And is it a
total perversion of whether God gives
you temp- allows temptations and trials?
So, is it basically two different
Bibles? See, see, in
then here in the second one, the NIV,
you can blame God if you get trials.
Yes. You can tell him, "But you said in
the word that I won't have any." I just
had a phone call yesterday of someone
who was very upset
because there are trials.
Now, why doesn't God do something about
it? Trials are God's way
of cleaning away the dross.
And he promised us trials.
And uh
when he suggested that this would be the
case
to John and his brother, he said, "Can
you drink the cup?" "Oh, yes, we can."
He says, "Okay, you will drink
And they had to drink it, right?
So, trials
yes, but God will not allow you to be
tempted beyond what you can endure. That
is a promise.
Let's have a look at Job.
For I know that my redeemer lives, Job
19:25,
and that he shall stand at the latter
day upon the earth.
And though after my skin worms destroy
this body, yet in my flesh shall I see
God, whom I shall see for myself for my
eyes shall behold and not another though
my reins be consumed within me.
Though my inner organs be dissolved,
though my kidney
gets eaten by worms, I will see him with
my flesh. I will be resurrected. That's
what it means, right?
In the latter day. Yes, in the latter
day. Now, let's read the American
Standard Version.
But as for me, I know that my redeemer
liveth and at last he will stand upon
the earth. There's a difference between
at last and the latter days, right?
Finally.
You could read it like that, right?
And after my skin, even this body is
destroyed, then without my flesh shall I
see God.
Martin is he now Casper the ghost or
what? It's exactly the opposite.
Whom I, even I, shall see on my side and
my eyes shall behold and not a stranger.
My heart is consumed within me. So, the
American Standard Version
totally destroys this doctrine.
And by the way, if we compare it with
the previous one,
then we have exactly the same problem
here, right?
Yeah.
So, the doctrine of the state of the
dead
is destroyed.
Now, some will argue, "Yes, but you can
still find it in other places." No, but
This is such a such a nonsensical
argument because does God
give us such a selection and so much
choice in his Bible that we can believe
either of the two doctrines?
By adding just one little note, one
little drop of toxin to confuse the mind
which is it now? Yeah. You have a
problem.
If God is God and his word is immutable,
then it will be consistent. That's the
beauty of the word.
And if some verses are hard to
understand,
then you must collect them with verses
that are easy to understand. Then you
know the context and then you must apply
the difficult in the context of that
which is plain. Yeah.
You don't argue from the difficult to
your doctrine. You argue from the simple
to your doctrine and then the difficult
has to fit in
with the plain statements of God.
All right, what about the doctrine of
clean and unclean?
And he said unto them, this is Mark 7:18
and 19 in the King James Version.
Are you so without understanding also?
Do you not perceive that whatsoever
things from without entereth into a man,
it cannot defile him? Because it
entereth not into his heart,
but into his belly and goes out in the
draft purging all meats. Now, remember
that meats in the King James simply
refers to food.
This has nothing to do with clean and
unclean foods in the first place. It has
to do with spiritual defilement. That
which your eyes perceive, your ears
hear, that you internalize in your
heart.
So, the food that you eat goes in and
you purge it. You get rid of it. A very
nice, clean way of saying what happens
biologically.
Let's read the NIV.
"Are you so dull?" he asked. "Don't you
see that nothing that enters a man from
the outside can make him unclean?
For it doesn't go into his heart, but
into his stomach and then out of his
body." In saying this, Jesus declared
all foods clean.
So, let's just read this little summary
that I wrote here. This That last bit is
typical of a dynamic equivalent
translation
whereby the interpretive rather than the
actual meaning of the text is rendered.
The context of this verse does not deal
with the issue of unclean foods, but
rather with the state of the
unregenerated
heart.
So, does it matter, Martin, that the new
translation remove the obligation to
observe God's health laws?
Of course.
Of course it matters, right? Without our
health message and the spirit of
prophecy, they become a byword.
Now, not only that,
the Old Testament becomes a byword.
And that's how easily people can say,
"But we on the new covenant, we throw
away the old."
All right. Now, let's take a simple
thing.
Was it wrong to eat blood in the Old
Testament? Yes.
Did the Jerusalem Council declare that
it was wrong to eat blood in the New
Testament?
Yes.
They did.
Does the German nation eat blood
sausage? Mhm. Mhm? On the strength of
what scripture did they find it
acceptable to do so? I don't know. It's
the most popular
state of your steak is medium rare.
That's exactly the same thing. So,
Martin, this is very interesting.
So, what the translators here in the NIV
thought
takes precedent of what
over what God said.
All right?
So,
when he says that if you have dealt with
a dead body, you need to wash your
hands.
Does that still stand or is it okay now
to to work with dead bodies and not wash
your hands? Still stands.
All right. Is it okay to no longer
practice hygiene when it comes to
discarding whatever comes out in the
draft?
Yeah, it's very important. It's still
relevant.
So, which portions of the health message
do they want to get rid of it rid of?
The food part. The food part. All right?
Did Jesus declare all foods clean? Does
it say that anywhere in the world in the
Bible? No. No.
So,
this is a travesty of justice. It gets
rid of a very important doctrine
and has changed humanity into what it is
today. A diseased
world in which we live.
All right?
So, modern versions also destroy the
identification of the little horn power
of Daniel. We've discussed that before.
Daniel 8 and 9 particularly in the
footnotes. So, they also destroy the
verses dealing with the physical state
of the prophet in vision. Now, I don't
even want to go into all of that.
But if you take
Daniel chapter 7
and you read there in the footnotes of
the NIV as to who the little horn power
is, they will tell you that it is
Antiochus Epiphanes, a Greek king.
And they shoot themselves in the foot
because the Bible says he comes out of
the fourth beast not out of the third
beast, which is a Greek empire. And
Antiochus was Greek. So, that doesn't
make any sense whatsoever.
And some study Bibles just leave out
that reference as well. But the
reformers were very clear
as to who that little horn power was,
right?
In fact, Martin Luther was so clear on
the issue that that's the first book he
translated of the Old Testament
just to make sure.
And then also all the verses that deal
with the physical state of the prophet
in vision.
I mean, the Bible is so clear as to how
a prophet goes into vision when you read
the book of Daniel.
Yes.
Firstly, he he loses all strength.
Then he falls down and his eyes are
open.
Then he is touched and he receives
superhuman strength and he speaks even
though there is no breath in him. You
try and find that in the new
translations.
It's so garbled and depending on which
one you read, the eyes are
closed
or
he can hardly breathe or whatever. But
all of those prophecies are gone.
So, you cannot even determine anymore
whether someone is a false prophet on
the strength of the manifestations or
not. This very important when you apply
it to the spirit of prophecy and Ellen
G. White.
That's it. Who in public
before thousands of people and doctors
and medical doctors was in vision and
exactly complied to all the conditions
as they are written in the received
text.
Yes.
So, let's not go into all of those
details or else we will talk for a very
long time. But just up to now, the basic
pillars of Adventism, have they been
removed in the new translations? Yes,
you cannot stand on what the new
translation say. Correct. So, if you
want to write a a lesson
or a study guide on any of these things
and you only use the new translation,
well, then you have to ignore Adventist
doctrine cuz you cannot you cannot bring
it to the fore, right?
So, let's just look at the commandments
because this becomes very interesting.
Psalms 119:151,
"Thou art near, O Lord, and all thy
commandments are truth." King James
Version.
If you go to the New International
Version, it says, "Yet you are near,
Lord, and all your commands are true."
Now, it looks like a minor change,
but actually, it is a major change.
Now, sometimes in the scripture, you
could probably use commands. "Whatever I
have commanded you."
But sometimes, very specifically, it's
commandments, referring to Exodus and
Deuteronomy, right? Correct.
And you have to be very careful how you
do this. By changing it to commands, you
have already generalized it.
So, Martin, when we look at this issue
of commandments and commands,
who would have a motive
for taking the attention away from the
commandments? The Antichrist. The
Antichrist.
Yes.
Because Daniel says very plainly
that he will change times and laws,
referring to the Ten Commandments. Now,
Rome removed the Second Commandment.
It changed the Fourth Commandment so
that it no longer reads what it reads,
and it refers to Sunday, and it becomes
the Third Commandment, although it is
the Fourth Commandment.
The others remain more or less the same,
except when it comes to the Tenth
Commandment, they divide it into two and
leave out the portions where they feel
that you should not have control, but
they should have control.
So, they have a motive
to speak against the commandments. Let's
just make sure whether they do.
Well, Martin, here's an article in the
journal America, as we have discussed
many times. This is the Jesuit review.
This is the journal of the Jesuits in
the United States.
And they are saying, "Pope Francis,
those who insist on keeping the truth of
a preaching the gospel have always
threatened the church."
As we've already said, one of the
definitions of truth is that the
commandments are truth, right?
Yes.
So, if you keep the truth, that means
you're keeping the commandments.
And indeed, today too, there is no
shortage of preachers who, especially
through the new means of communication,
can disturb communities. They present
themselves not primarily to announce the
gospel of God
who loves man in Jesus, crucified and
risen, but to insist, as true keepers of
the truth,
so they call themselves, on the best way
to be Christians.
And they strongly affirm that the true
Christianity is the one they adhere to,
often identified with certain forms of
the past, and that the solution to the
crisis of today is to go back so as not
to lose the genuineness of the faith.
One of the traces of this way of
proceeding is inflexibility.
Faced with the preaching of the gospel
that makes us free,
that makes us joyful,
these people are rigid. Always the
rigidity. You must do this, you must do
that. Inflexibility is typical of these
people.
The new preachers do not know what
humility is, what fraternity is. It is
the path of the meek and obedient trust.
The new preachers know neither meekness
nor obedience.
What are they referring to here, Martin?
It's referring to people that speaking
like us.
And that speak about the truth and
certain things of the past.
Uh
that is opening up the history and
talking about the commandments, all all
these issues.
So, to make it quite plain, the Jesuits
also tell us in the American review that
Pope Francis says that an encounter with
Jesus is more important than all the
commandments.
In other words, what he's talking about
is spiritual exercises of Loyola, where
you have an encounter experience.
So, that which you feel, that which you
encounter in your spiritualistic
attitude towards
the gospel, is more important than the
commandments. Yes. That which they
perceive the Holy Spirit to be telling
you through your experience.
Yes, and your own conscience, which
supersedes
the word of God.
So, he quotes here, "The apostle writes,
'If you are led by the spirit, you are
not under the law.'" Now, look how he
distorts this.
"Instead, Paul's detractors sustained
that the Galatians had to follow the law
to be saved."
Who did that?
The detractors.
"They were going backwards. They were
nostalgic for times gone by, of the
times before Jesus Christ. The apostle
is not at all in agreement. He's here
totally confusing two laws."
As do many others. Yes. The moral law
and the ceremonial law. If it goes to
Galatians, most people are And Galatians
is a difficult book because it refers to
both laws.
But when you are not under the law, it
means you are not under the condemnation
of the law
because you have accepted Jesus Christ.
And he stood in your place. He stood in
your place. But if God paid the price
for your sin, does that give you license
now to sin?
No. And if he had to pay the price for
the transgression of the law, that does
not negate and take away the law.
Absolutely. Now, just think of the
illogical
gospel that they have.
If Satan was thrown out of heaven on a
permanent basis
for transgression of the law, according
to this,
if you are a transgressor, you're
welcome in heaven.
Aren't you then replacing one set of
transgressors with another set of
transgressors?
No.
If you accept salvation in Christ,
then that means that your sin has been
forgiven. Sin is transgression of the
law, and the next step is go and sin no
more. No longer transgress the law of
God. So, this is absolute
contrary to what the Bible teaches. And
unfortunately, not only the Pope,
but a large portion of the evangelical
world swallows this.
So, they were nostalgic for the times
gone by, of the times before Jesus. The
apostle is not at all in agreement.
"These were not the terms he had agreed
on with the other apostles in Jerusalem.
He remembered very well Peter's words
when he said, 'Why do you make trial of
God by putting a yoke upon the neck of
the disciples, which neither our fathers
nor we have been able to bear?'" This is
talking about ceremonial issues.
Circumcision. Circumcision and all of
these issues has nothing to do with the
Ten Commandments.
So, this is an attitude. The article
continues.
"The apostle explains to the Galatians
that the reality, the covenant, and the
law are not linked indissolubly."
Interesting. But Jesus said, "I've not
come to abolish the law."
So, he didn't come to dissolve it,
right? But he says it could be
dissolved.
"The covenant with God and the Mosaic
Law, the first element it relies on is
that the covenant established by God
with Abraham was based on faith
in the fulfillment of the promise and
not in the observance of the law that
did not yet exist." Excuse me.
"Abraham kept my commandments,
my decrees, and my laws."
So, how could the law not have existed?
And the Bible is quite clear.
"Where there is no law,
there is no transgression."
So, if Adam and Eve transgressed, was
there a law? Exactly. They should have
It's no other way. The law is immutable.
So, this is a totally nonsensical
argument. "Abraham began his journey
centuries before the law. Then how is it
that the Bible says that he kept his
law?"
"With this reasoning, Paul reached his
first objective. The law is not the
basis of the covenant because it came
later."
He's confusing the ceremonial law with
the moral law. Completely. And I think
if anyone wants to see, they can watch
the episode that we did on the
covenants. Yes. The covenants are part
of the law.
You cannot divorce them.
"It was necessary and just, but prior to
that, there was the promise, the
covenant.
Such an argument disqualifies all those
who sustained that the Mosaic law was a
constitutive part of the covenant. No,
the covenant comes first and the call
came to Abraham, the Torah, the law, in
fact, was not included in the promise
made to Abraham.
This is the most confused statement that
I have ever read out of the pen of the
Jesuits.
Well, again, unfortunately, most of the
evangelical world believe the same.
All right, here's another article from
the
National Catholic Reporter. Holiness
does not come from following rigid
rules, Pope says.
Redemption is the work of God, not of
human beings, so be careful and do not
listen to fundamentalists who claim
holiness comes through following certain
laws.
Pope Francis said during his weekly
general
audience.
The belief that holiness comes by
observing particular laws leads us to a
rigid religiosity, a rigidity that
eliminates the freedom of the spirit
which Christ redemption gives us. Beware
of this rigidity
that they propose, he said, September 1,
to those gathered in Paul VI audience
hall at the Vatican.
Martin
The Bible says
in keeping it, there is great reward.
This man says, beware of keeping it
rigidly. And then there the people make
it a joke to keep the 10 Commandments,
where Jesus said, my yoke is easy. And
like we've said, the truth shall make
you free. Yes. And Jesus is quite plain
that he says, if you break one of the
least of these Commandments, you will be
called least in the kingdom of heaven.
And a little later, he says, they will
not be in heaven.
Uh, what shall I do to inherit eternal
life? Keep the Commandments.
So, this is totally unscriptural.
So, let's read that verse. Think not
that I've come to destroy the law of the
prophets.
I'm not come to destroy, but to fulfill.
For verily, I say unto you, till heaven
and earth pass, one jot or one tittle
shall in no wise pass from the law till
all be fulfilled. Whoever therefore
shall break one of these least
Commandments and shall teach men so,
he shall be called least in the kingdom
of heaven. But whoever shall do and
teach them the same shall be called
great in the kingdom of heaven. Martin,
did the papacy change the Commandments?
So, did they break the least ones or
even the greatest ones? All of All of
them. So, what will they be? Least in
the kingdom of heaven and later, it
says, they won't be there.
1 John 2:4, he that says, I know him and
keeps not his Commandments is a liar and
the truth is not in him. So, would that
apply to the Pope now? Yes.
Unfortunately, yes.
Is there a possibility that the man can
repent or has he already committed the
sin against the Holy Spirit?
Well, that's between him and God.
Excellent.
All right. Now,
let's just look at this this word
Commandments.
The word Commandments occurs in 168
verses in the King James,
of which 30 are found in the New
Testament.
In the NIV, the word Commandments is
found in 20 verses, of which six are
found in the New Testament.
All right, so we're down from 168 verses
to 20 verses
and from 30 down to six.
The word command
occurs in zero verses in the King James.
They don't use the word.
But it occurs in 184 verses in the NIV.
Now,
is it just a nuance?
Now, the NIV translates the same Hebrew
and Greek words, depending whether it's
Old Testament or New Testament,
for Commandments, sometimes the same
word. Sometimes they translate it as
Commandments,
but mostly, as we see, as commands.
Whereas the King James is consistent in
its translation of the Hebrew and Greek
words as Commandments.
Now, why do they sometimes
use Commandments, but mostly commands?
Well, sometimes they have no choice
because it refers directly to the 10
Commandments, the law, then they will
use Commandments, but they'll only do
that six times.
And that same word,
they will translate command anywhere
else.
That is deceptive, Martin, in my
opinion.
That's to bring to put through their
ideas. All right. Now, we just read what
the Pope said.
Now, what the Pope says is, you know,
don't take it so seriously.
Which word would he prefer, Commandments
or command? Command, definitely.
Now, do you understand why they Catholic
approved Bibles?
Let's go to a very important verse when
it comes to the doctrine.
Revelation 22:14, Blessed are they that
do his Commandments,
that they may have the right to the tree
of life and may enter in through the
gates into the city.
Now, the NIV changes that and the modern
translations in general,
Blessed are those who wash their robes,
that they may have the right to the tree
of life and may go through the gates
into the city.
Now, which one is it, Martin?
Is it Commandments or is it wash their
robes?
It has to be Commandments.
And if it wanted if they wanted to put
robes in there, it would have to have
added the words in his blood.
Aha, correct.
Now,
let's just unpack this a little bit. The
claim for the NIV
is that the rendition wash their robes
is found in the Synaiticus,
which was found in a waste paper basket
where it belongs,
the Vaticanus, which was found in the
Vatican library,
Vulgate,
and a few Alexandrian manuscripts.
However, the church fathers
that quoted these verses long before
they were written in these manuscripts,
Synaiticus, Vaticanus, etc., all quoted
do his Commandments. Isn't that
interesting?
It's very interesting. So, these include
Tertullian, AD 299,
Cyprian, AD 248 to 258, Tatonius, AD
390.
The first quote, wash their robes, was
Athanasius, Bishop of Alexandria in the
4th century, AD 326 to 373. So, the
early pens thus knew nothing of wash
their robes.
So, how did that sneak in there, Martin?
This comes from George Burnside, the New
International Version or the King James
Version,
Leaves of Autumn Books. This is
extremely important
because I've had numerous people tell me
uh, the word actually the words actually
used in the
original
cannot be translated Commandments. Well,
let's have a look.
it's it comes out from which original
Greek and
are they talking about?
So, let's have a look at the ancient
Syriac
also reads do his Commandments, as also
the Coptic version.
And the spirit of prophecy quotes this
verse many times and always from the
King James Version.
In early writings, she mentions how
corrupt scribes altered words of
scripture. Note how easily this verse is
actually altered.
Here is the keep his Commandments
statements.
And as we see,
it is very similar to wash their robes.
So, hoi
poiantes tas entolas auto
whether that pronunciation is correct or
not is neither here nor there. Read what
it says on the screen.
Here, there's a slight change. Hoi
plunontes tas stolas
auton.
That's wash their robes.
So, let's go to that quote in early
writings. Jesus threw open the gates of
the golden city and let us in.
Here, we were made welcome for we had
kept the Commandments of God and had the
right to the tree of life. Very clear.
So, Martin,
the stola.
You are very interested in this little
word stola that they love to incorporate
in some of the new translations, right?
In the new 2020 direct translation of
the Afrikaans Bible, they didn't even
change that Greek. They left it like
that. They kept the stolas. Mhm.
But as we see,
in the
in the received text, it's not there.
It's entolas and not stolas.
Now, what is stole a Martin?
It's a priestly kingly
uh garment. Aha. Now, who wears that
garment? The priests and the kings. So,
are they the only ones that go to
heaven?
Well, if you unfortunately read that
part, it's
it's nonsensical
because it says
blessed are they that wash their stole
us in and they will have the
So, the priests go to heaven and the
rest of us don't get there. Is that how
it works?
It's so ridiculous, Martin.
The received text is very plain on this
issue and the King James is very plain
on this issue as well.
So, if we have harmony between the Bible
and the spirit of prophecy and we have
harmony with the the scriptures that
come from
uh the Byzantine stable and we have
harmony with the early church fathers
that quoted that verse in that way, then
why is the world so insistent on
changing it? Because they want to get
rid of the commandments. Absolutely.
Okay, and then another thing, if you
read that whole chapter
in the context, it definitely makes
sense to put it in
the commandments in there. And if you
read the 15th verse,
it says outside are these and these and
these
and that comes through to people that
don't keep the commandments because it's
What they are doing on the outside is
contrary to the law of God. It's very
simple. And uh it is a a story of
contrast. These are those that won't
make it and these are those that will
make it. It's very simple. Their
translation makes no sense. As you say,
if they at least had said wash their
robes in the blood of the lamb,
but what washing powder was that were
they going to use?
if we if you put this in context, this
that was done deliberately because like
we saw it comes out of those paper
basket manuscripts.
It's so it it's if it was done with a
received text,
it wouldn't have happened.
You know, the possibility that
Tischendorf was an agent of Rome because
he constantly visited the Rome and
dedicated his manuscripts to the Pope.
Well,
that must tell you something. These
people that were involved in in this
kind of skulduggery
were definitely on the side of the
enemy.
Now, Martin, people also say, "Well, you
know, be that as it may, I'm sorry, I
won't be able to read
uh the King James version, for example."
And let's make it quite plain again.
At no stage had we have we ever said
that we are King James only. No, we are
received text only. And for those that
want to say, "Okay, but the King the
King James is the most reliable in the
English language." Like you said, the
Geneva Bible as well, but that's
if you think the King James is difficult
to read, go and try that one. Yes.
And the same with all the older versions
in the other language that were
translated from the received text. So,
you cannot say
that one only. Yes. Well, as I said,
uh
when the King James came out, there was
a lot of reluctance to actually
uh start using it
because the people clung to their Geneva
Bibles, but of course the language
became a problem, Chaucer's English and
all of that.
But the difficulty
mm
that is supposedly there
disappears once you start understanding
a few simple rules
Yes. as to why they use ye and thee and
your and thine, etc. We've discussed
that in a previous one, so we're not
going to discuss that again. And I may
can also maybe just add again that
for somebody that hasn't studied these
things like me for a long time,
the spirit of prophecy is a amazing help
that God gave to us
Yes. in studying.
Now, once you start reading it in the
King James
and you start understanding the
parallelism
nominative accusative, why they use
thee, thine, thou,
then it it starts opening up the book.
And then the language is so poetic.
Mm. For some
inexplicable reason,
the translators not only succeeded in
translating what God actually said,
but also managed to include the poetry,
which is an amazing feat when you think
that you are translating from one
language to another.
And people that say, "Well,
uh they want it in a plainer language."
Mm. When you you when you start losing
the poetic language, when you start
losing the finesse
and the brilliance of word usage,
well, then you come down to the level of
the mundane.
Even if you don't want to go into the
poetic part of it, the other plain
statements are still quite plain in the
King James as well.
Well,
we have an article here that was written
by Peter Mullen and he is a Church of
England clergyman.
He's also a writer and a broadcaster.
And this article comes from December the
5th, 2021.
So, it's not very old.
And he laments the fact that the modern
versions have brought the language down
to the level of the mundane.
And uh I thought it might be useful to
read some of the things that he said for
those people who think
that they need a very plainer language.
Because very often the plain language
that the modern versions are translated
in
are almost blasphemous in the way in
which they state things. Now, let's read
a little bit of what he has to say.
So, let's discuss the argument about
language that it is too difficult to
understand.
So, here are a few statements. The King
James Bible avoid all imitations, Peter
Mullen.
Here's a glimpse of glory for you.
And then he makes a quote here of a
statement that the church brought out.
Blessed Lord, who has caused all holy
scriptures to be written for our
learning,
grant that we may in such wise hear
them, read, mark, learn, and inwardly
digest them, that by patience and
comfort of thy holy word we may embrace
and ever hold fast the blessed hope of
everlasting life,
which thou hast given us in our Savior
Jesus Christ.
Amen. Now, this was a prayer that they
used for a special occasion.
So, he explains,
"That is the collect for the second
Sunday in Advent today, commonly called
Bible Sunday." So, that's what they read
on that particular day.
"So, let me celebrate the Bible this
morning, the real thing. That is the
King James version of 1611.
Beware of alternatives, which are as
numerous and nasty as a plague of flies.
There's no such thing as noble truth
expressed in ignoble words.
For the choice of words determines what
is being said. Therefore, we should
choose the best." That's his opinion.
And I thought it best to let him state
his opinion rather than me or you state
your opinion when it comes to the choice
of the language.
And then he gives a few example. "Strips
of cloth
is no substitute for swaddling clothes.
And Mary was with child.
We think of the Madonna and child. She
had not fallen pregnant as it says in
one of those God-forsaken modern
versions.
You cannot satisfactorily replace
through a glass darkly with the cross
literalism puzzling reflections in a
mirror
or sounding brass and tinkling cymbal
with noisy gong and clanging cymbal.
The King James was designed to be read
aloud in the churches. All the modern
versions sound as if they have been
written by people with tin ears and no
rhythm.
I don't know whether you concur so far,
Martin, but let us keep our opinion out
of this lest it be said that this is
altogether our opinion.
The real Bible says,
"The fear of the Lord is the beginning
of wisdom."
The New English Bible gives us instead,
"The first step to find wisdom, God save
us, and then if you are ever so good
little children, I'll show you the
second step." This is infantilization.
He says, "Now, really, do you want to
replace this beautiful sentence, 'The
fear of the Lord is the beginning of
wisdom' with 'The first step to find
wisdom'? It's so flat.
Sometimes the pedantry of the New
Jerusalem Bible
its pseudo-scholarly fascination with
all that is merely foreign and obscure.
By the way, the New Jerusalem Bible is
a Catholic Bible.
It's just silly as in "You are Yahweh,
examine me." That's That sounds
blasphemous, doesn't it, Martin?
Is that the way you speak to God?
But occasionally, it is mindlessly
unpoetic and banal
as in the substitution of a claim Yahweh
for the mesmerizingly beautiful and
timelessly familiar "Make a joyful noise
unto the Lord."
And in one example of supreme idiocy,
the meaning becomes impenetrable.
The King James says, "He that dwelleth
in the secret place of the most high
shall abide under the shadow of the
almighty."
"I will say of the Lord, etc. etc." The
New Jerusalem Bible
This degenerates into a tasteless
obscurantism.
If you live in the shelter of Elion and
make your home in the shadow of Shaddai,
you can say to Yahweh
Sounds terrible, doesn't it?
The New English Bible cannot tell the
difference between speech that is poetic
and metaphorical and speech that is
literal and descriptive.
That is why for wolves in sheep's
clothing
we are given instead the pantomime
howler, men dressed up as sheep.
We recall perhaps Ulysses' escape from
the Cyclops
or that pejorative expression mutton
dressed as lamb.
In the King James version, men are at
meat or they sup.
But the RSV mentions a Pharisee who
asked Jesus to dine.
Where? At the Garrick or White's?
Likewise, our Lord rebukes to the
disciple on the road to Emmaus, "O fools
and slow of heart." is emasculated to
become "How dull you are."
How dull indeed. Can you imagine for one
minute Jesus Christ on the evening of
his day of resurrection using such
language?
There is a discreet charm about the King
James version saying "It ceased to be
with Sarah after the manner of women."
This is marvelous. It seems to reach up
to the underclothes of words as that
other great admirer of biblical prose,
Dylan Thomas, said.
But the NJB was written in the era of
sex education, so it can confidently
come straight out with "Ceased to have
her monthly periods."
Can you imagine that, Martin? "Ceased to
have her monthly periods" with "It
ceased to be with Sarah after the manner
of women."
And that is beautifully discreet.
And the King James version's great
of Babylon seems to have lost what she
had left of her character when the New
Jerusalem Bible refers to her only as
the famous prostitute. Who is this,
then? Eskimo Nell?
With costive pedantry, the New Jerusalem
Bible replaces in with living space.
I suppose because they imagined readers
to be so literal-minded that we might
think St. Luke meant the Rosicrucian.
A similar pedantry removes the King
James's lovely coat of many colors and
offers us a decorated tunic.
How hypocritical and sordid of the
church authorities relentlessly to
suppress the King James
only to take it out and gawk at it at
coronation or the state funeral of a man
as singular as Winston Churchill
as if it were a museum piece and we were
all blundering tourists.
The proper place for the King James
version is on the lectern in every
parish church to be read, marked,
learned, inwardly digested week in and
week out.
Now, Martin, that is the opinion of this
one man.
Now
I have read the Bibles in the various
translations and I must concur.
Once you start getting into the literary
style
into the poetry of the Bible
then there is a certain beauty about it.
"It ceased to be with Sarah after the
manner of women." It's It's It's just
sublime.
Or "Listen up, Yahweh."
I mean, that is That is so blasphemous,
I can't even read it anymore.
So, Martin, Psalms 119:105
says, "Thy word is a lamp unto my feet
and a light unto my path."
And Joshua in 1:8 says, "This book of
the law
shall not depart out of thy mouth
but thou shalt meditate therein day and
night
that thou mayest observe to do according
to all that is written therein.
For then thou shalt make thy way
prosperous
and then shalt thou have good success."
That's beautiful, isn't it?
That's putting your you at ease that you
can read the complete truth if you read
the word of God.
So, let's put this subject to rest now.
We have said our say.
And this is what we believe because in
our opinion
it is important that the Bible not only
reflect the character
of God
even in the choice of language
that it also gives us a sense of
reverence
and that the doctrine is sound
and not contradictory.
Then we can have confidence that we are
reading what God really said. So, may
God give us wisdom when we study the
Bible. Amen. Let's pray.
Heavenly Father
this issue of the word
has been a war
ever since
you made the Bible available to people
in their own language.
The Jesuits called the King James
version that poisonous asp and they
couldn't wait to grab it by the tail and
destroy it.
They seem to have done a good job, Lord.
And when we read in the Bibles, whether
it be in English or Afrikaans or any
other language, French or
Spanish or Portuguese or any other
language in the world
Lord, help us to make sure that we read
what God really said.
Bless our people as we study the
scripture, internalize its truths and
live according to its precepts in Jesus'
name. Amen. Amen.